the Christmas season is upon us I'm
Walter been a ZX I'm Heather Roos and
I'm a Hannah wave and this is top five
there are so many wonderful images that
pop into people's heads when you think
of the holidays Santa hot cocoa
presents don't forget murder what oh
yeah and nightmare-inducing monsters
this is supposed to be a nice warm
holiday top five do you know the top
five best Christmas horror movies number
five Silent Night deadly night this 1984
slasher movie was so controversial when
it first premiered it was pulled from
theaters almost a week after its opening
Silent Night deadly night is a story of
Billy on Christmas Eve his family is on
the way home for visiting their grandpa
at a state mental facility there Billy's
grandpa tells him that Santa not only
brings presents to those who are good
but punishes those who have been naughty
this instills an unhealthy fear of Santa
that grows once his parents are brutally
murdered that night by a man wearing a
Santa costume Billy runs away but
watches the whole thing he and his
brother survived and are taken to an
orphanage while he is there Billy is
abused by some nuns who try to force him
to overcome his fear and PTSD associated
with Santa the Mother Superior also
teaches him the important lesson that
punishment is absolute punishment is
necessary
punishment is good billy grows into a
young adult and of course ends up
working for a toy store on Christmas Eve
he is asked to play Santa this is one
step too far for Billy he snaps and
begins going on a murder rampage to
punish all the naughty people this movie
is exactly what you would expect it to
be
it's a gory slasher film about a killer
Santa it's kind of fun and dramatic
expect lots of fake blood crazy eyes and
interesting ways to kill people if that
sounds like it's right up your alley
enjoy this film with the rest of the
cult following it has accumulated over
the years
number four rare exports a Christmas
tale this film took a sinister angle on
the legend of Santa Claus and has since
become a cult classic in the Finnish
mountains on the border of Finland and
Russia an excavation team is drilling
deep into the ice what they're looking
for is an exactly jolly old Saint Nick a
young boy named PRT discovers that
they're trying to dig up the tomb of the
original Santa Claus however the real
Santa is a much more demonic figure that
kidnaps and beats naughty children
now PR T's friends are all disappearing
and his father captures a sickly looking
man with a long white beard the truth
behind these strange occurrences gives a
whole new meaning to here come Santa
Claus I know not everyone likes reading
subtitles but rare exports is worth it
there are some English speaking segments
as the leader of the excavation team is
supposed to be American this is not sand
what it's one of Santa's little helpers
it close enough in this world the
coca-cola Santa Claus is said to have
been alive when all that mythology
starts to play out around the characters
we get some really unsettling scenes
especially with the old man P Artie's
father is captured
so yo the tone is set here by some great
cinematography it really captures the
eerie feeling in the air and showcases
the environment well
[Music]
purity is a solid character that we get
to see shine towards the end of the film
he solidifies this movie status as
something special while the visuals and
lore make rare exports an unmissable
creepy Christmas tale number three
Krampus I hope you've been good this
year because agent Santa has come to
punish your entire family Merry
Christmas
the opening to Krampus was one of my
favorites it's beginning to look a lot
like Christmas plays while hordes of
Black Friday shoppers fight over sales
the imagery is an honest reflection of
modern holiday consumerism Tom and Sarah
get ready for their extended family to
visit while their son Max writes his
letter to Santa when the rest of the
family arrives we see that the two sides
are very different
Sarah tries to be organized in welcoming
while her sister Linda thinks she's fake
and stuck-up at dinner
Max's cousins find his letter to Santa
and read it out loud to embarrass him
humiliated max runs to his room ribbing
up the letter and losing hope for the
holidays
unbeknownst to max this sets off a
winter Blizzard that affects the entire
neighborhood Max's sister Beth goes into
the snowstorm to check on her boyfriend
but never returns Tom and his
brother-in-law Howard go looking for
Beth but are attacked by some terrible
creature hiding beneath the snow when
they return everyone boards up the
windows and listens to Max's Oh me tell
her story about losing hope as a young
girl her experience with Krampus cost
her everyone closest to her since he
punishes all the families and not just
the children I like that everyone had to
put their differences aside to take on
this force of evil but the best part of
the movie was definitely the Santa's
little helpers and holy crap they were
terrifying there were elves and
gingerbread men and a teddy bear and
this flying angel baby thing oh and we
can't forget the horrific giant
jack-in-the-box that has retractable
jaws for eating children don't get me
wrong Krampus is creepy and his design
was cool too but keep that
jack-in-the-box away from me and the
gingerbread men while you're at it
[Music]
number two gremlins no Sun no water and
no feeding after midnight everyone
remembers the rules for caring for Maude
why Randall Peltzer buys a rare animal
in Chinatown and brings it home for his
son Billy it's called a Mogwai and there
are very strict rules to keep anything
from happening to them after bonding
with this sweet little creature he
dubbed gizmo Billy's friend accidentally
gets gizmo wet causing him to multiply
the new Mogwai are a lot more
mischievous and trick Billy into feeding
them after midnight this causes a
metamorphosis into the evil gremlin form
this new form is messy violent and
rollicking
[Music]
[Applause]
then the movie gives legitimately gross
and suspenseful the evil gremlins led by
stripe try to destroy the town and
Billy's mother Lin has an entire scene
of killing them in her kitchen she stabs
microwaves and even juices one its core
but it's green blood so we're getting
away with a lot under the PG rating of
course Billy has to save the town with
gizmo and his love interest Kate while
making sure no more gremlins duplicate
in the process highlights of this movie
include Randall the father whose Lion
deliveries were hilarious and gizmo who
was the obvious fan favorite this is
your reminder that how he meant L voiced
gizmo this movie held up surprisingly
well and gizmo really is as adorable and
heartbreaking as I remembered
[Music]
and the number one best Christmas horror
movie is black Christmas black Christmas
is considered one of the earliest modern
slasher films and heavily influenced his
successors specifically Halloween the
premise of the movie is pretty
straightforward and one a modern
audience is very familiar with a group
of young ladies live together at a
sorority house to begin receiving
obscene phone calls from mysterious man
who threatens to kill them it's the
holiday season though so these calls are
brushed off as a creeper as some of the
ladies leave for Christmas there are a
couple of girls though who are left at
the house we see a first-person point of
view of a man climbing up the ivy of the
house and breaking into the Attic and
well you can probably see where this is
going this general idea was an urban
myth and legend at the time of the
film's release but not the same
predictable horror trope that we know it
asked today in fact you can see many
elements in the film that would become
tropes and staples in the slasher film
genre the movie in and of itself is
incredibly creepy without being too gory
it builds suspense really well even
though I felt like I knew it was going
to happen I was still enthralled and on
the edge of my seat
every time the phone rang I felt like I
had to prepare myself because the calls
were just so unnerving some of the
images are bone-chilling but perhaps the
creepiest element is the ending so
spoiler warning here the movie leads us
to believe that one of the girls
boyfriends has become mentally unstable
and as the killer
but then we see the first person cam
review that is associated with the
killer as he climbs back into the Attic
with the bodies of the first two people
who he murdered the killer was never
caught and we never know for certain if
he killed the only surviving woman he's
still out there waiting for his next
group of victims
you guys remember Vernon Wells from
commando Mad Max - the road warrior and
Power Rangers time force well I'm in a
movie with him yes really and yes that's
my real hair it's called City of Gold
and it's available now on Amazon Hulu
iTunes Google Play and more a DVD
release is also set for January 1st 2019
I have an interview up with the director
of the film over on my personal channel
so check that out for more information
or go straight to City of Gold the movie
com we want to hear what you guys think
what's your favorite Christmas horror
movie what do you want to see us cover
next on the show leave a comment and let
us know to keep in touch you could like
my Facebook page or follow along on
Twitter you can find me on Facebook
Twitter Instagram or subscribe to my
animated movie review series right here
on YouTube and you can find me on
Twitter Instagram or Twitter I stream on
Wednesday nights we'll catch you back
here next week with a spectacular new
episode of top pop
[Music]
[Applause]
you